Great.
You're done.
Let me show you how I
implemented this one.
Inside of detail fragment,
within detail activity.
First, of course,
we add a constant for the loader.
I've also added a projection for the
columns I want to get from the database.
And, of course, corresponding constants.
Then we have our detail fragment
implement our loader callbacks for
cursor loader.
Of course,
with parametrized type cursor.
In on create loader.
We create a new cursor loader for
the URI that came in from the intent.
In onLoadFinished, I format a string to
match what was in the original forecast
fragment and set it to the mForecast
variable as well as the TextView.
We don't have to do anything
with onLoaderReset.
Because there isn't any data that we
were holding onto that needs to be
cleaned up.
But, how do we fix the share intent?
I start by creating a member variable
for the share action provider.
I set this variable in
on create options menu.
Only if we have a forecast.
We don't make any assumptions about
the order in which our loader happens.
Finally in onload finish,
I set the share intent.
This will update the share action
provider if it already exists.
Let's make sure this still works.
The list as we would expect it to be and
when we click on one of these.
We get the detail view.
We even have a share action provider.
And as you can see, we can share it,
and there's our forecast.